Most people don't realise they're burned out until their body forces them to stop. But long before that, there's often a quieter face, one that people keep explaining away. Nothing's really wrong, but I don't feel like myself anymore. In this episode, myself and Dr Emma Hepburn, aka the Psychology Mum, known for making psychology visual and accessible through her brilliant drawings. Unpack what's really happening beneath the surface long before burnout breaks you. I hope you find it so useful if you do like and subscribe for more. Hi, I just want to welcome along Dr Emma Hepburn,
大多数人在身体强迫他们停下来之前，并没有意识到自己已经精疲力竭了。但在那之前很久，通常会有一种更安静的迹象，人们总是试图为它找借口。没什么大不了的，但我感觉自己不再是以前的那个我了。在这一集中，我和被称为“心理学妈妈”（Psychology Mum）的艾玛·赫本（Dr Emma Hepburn）博士一起，她以通过精彩的绘图让心理学变得直观且易于理解而闻名。我们将剖析在倦怠彻底击垮你之前，表面之下究竟发生了什么。希望你觉得这很有用，如果你喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，我想欢迎临床心理学家，也就是播客中的“心理学妈妈”艾玛·赫本博士。
clinical psychologist, also known as the psychology mum to the podcast. Hi Emma. Good afternoon or hello. Thank you for being here. Could you tell us a little bit about who the psychology mum is and how she came to be? Yeah, so I was working in the NHS. in a brain injury group and I was doing lots of illustrations for that because one of the things of working with brain injury is you need to be able to communicate things in a way that people
嗨，艾玛。下午好，或者说你好。谢谢你能来。你能告诉我们一点关于“心理学妈妈”是谁，以及她是如何诞生的吗？是的，当时我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的一个脑损伤小组工作，我为那个小组做了很多插图，因为在脑损伤领域工作的一件事是，你需要能够以人们
can remember and use in their day-to-day life. So as part of this brain injury group, I was doing these big kind of posters, hand-drawn, so the group could remember certain concepts and take them and use them. And they were really engaging with these. I also have always drawn as part of my clinical work. So sitting with children or people with neuropsychology, I've always done. drawn things, maybe their formulation or an idea we're talking about, giving it away with them just to do it. So I've always drawn. And I decided to try and make these posters a little bit better than NHS paper from the printer and start drawing them out on my iPad. So I started drawing them out. And I thought, you know, wouldn't it be great if actually more people could use these
能够记住并应用到日常生活中的方式来传达信息。所以作为这个脑损伤小组的一部分，我制作了这些大型的手绘海报，这样小组成员就能记住某些概念，并把它们带走使用。他们对这些海报非常感兴趣。我一直以来在临床工作中也会画画。所以和孩子们或神经心理学患者坐在一起时，我总是会画一些东西，也许是他们的构思，或者是我们正在讨论的一个想法，并把它们送给他们。所以我一直都在画画。我决定尝试把这些海报做得比NHS打印机打出来的纸张更好一些，并开始在我的iPad上画出来。所以我开始画它们。我想，如果实际上有更多的人能使用这些，那不是很好吗？
rather than just the 12 people I was currently working with or the one person you're working with in our clinic. So I thought, I'll start an Instagram account. And at the time, so it was at 2018, I think, there was very few psychologists on social media. And our social media guidelines were very, like, vague and unclear. So I was like, I don't know what this is going to, how this is going to be. I don't know how the profession will take this. So I didn't want my name on it. I didn't want to put it as Dr. Emma Hepburn. So I sat, I thought, what will I call it? And I said to my husband, he said, well, you're a psychologist and you're a mum. So why do you do that?
而不是仅仅局限于我当时工作的12个人，或者我们在诊所里接触的那一个人。所以我心想，我要开一个Instagram账号。当时是2018年，我想，社交媒体上的心理学家非常少。我们的社交媒体准则非常模糊且不明确。所以我当时想，我不知道这会变成什么样，不知道这个行业会如何看待这件事。所以我不想把我的名字放上去。我不想把它标注为“艾玛·赫本博士”。所以我坐下来思考，我该叫它什么呢？我问我丈夫，他说，嗯，你是一位心理学家，也是一位妈妈。那你为什么不叫那个名字呢？
I was like, okay, the psychology mum. So there wasn't really much thought to it, to be totally honest. So I started posting this, the psychology mum. And that's really become my kind of moniker or handle for the illustrations. So I still use that for the illustrations. So, you know, in the bottom left hand corner, somewhere in the illustration, there will always be the psychology mum. So it's like a kind of comic handle for it. So for a couple of years
我说，好吧，就叫“心理学妈妈”。老实说，我并没有太多的思考。所以我开始发布这些内容，以“心理学妈妈”的名义。这确实成为了我插图的某种绰号或账号名。所以我仍然在插图中使用它。所以，你知道，在插图的左下角，某个地方总会有“心理学妈妈”的标志。所以它就像是一个漫画式的账号名。所以几年下来，
I kept on putting things out and they were kind of people were really enjoying them people were picking up on them they were getting shared lots I hadn't really thought much about you know
我一直在发布内容，人们真的很喜欢它们，人们开始关注它们，它们被大量转发。我真的没有太考虑过，你知道，
what the aims were for social media if I'm totally honest I really didn't like social media much I had my own personal account I had about five friends in it most of it were my family so they kind of had to be friends with me so I didn't have much kind of
如果说实话，我真的不太喜欢社交媒体，我当时的目标是什么。我有自己的个人账号，大约有五个朋友，大部分都是我的家人，所以他们算是不得不和我做朋友，所以我对我在做什么并没有太多的概念，我只是觉得做一些有点不同的事情很酷。所以我没有把我的名字放上去。我没有露脸。我什么都没做。然后我想疫情爆发了，我开始像大多数心理学家一样，被重新部署到员工福利部门工作。所以我当时在医院的福利中心，听取人们在抗疫一线工作的经历，听取他们关于新冠疫情的经历。所以我回家后，需要消化这些内容。所以我开始把它们画出来。这就是我所听到的。
idea of what I was doing I just thought quite cool to do something a bit different. So I didn't have my name on it. I didn't show my face. I didn't do anything. And then I guess the pandemic hit and I started, like most psychologists, I got redeployed to work and staff wellbeing. So I was in a hospital wellbeing centre hearing people's experiences of working on the front line and hearing their experiences of COVID. So I would come home and I kind of needed to process this. So I started drawing them out. this is what I've been hearing.
显然，没有什么私人的，没有什么具体的我听到的内容。这就是它开始不断增长的时候。它被，你知道，我不擅长认识名人，但有人会说，某某转发了你的帖子，我会问，那是谁？但有些人我确实认识，比如艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特（Alanis Morissette），
Obviously, nothing personal, nothing specific I'd been hearing. And this is when it just started to grow and grow and grow. And it was getting shared by, you know, I'm not very good at known famous people, but somebody would say, well, so on so shared your post, and I'd be like, who's that? But some people I did know, so like Alanis Morissette,
你知道，开始关注我了。我就想，好吧，我认识她。所以，你知道，它就开始呈指数级增长。大约在同一时间，一家出版商找到我，让我写一本书。他们确实说，你不能继续使用化名。你需要把你的名字放上去，以增加你的可信度。他们需要知道你确实有资格。这些画作背后是有可信度的。
you know, started following me. I was like, okay, I know her. So, you know, it just started growing, growing and growing exponentially. And around the same time, I was approached by a publisher to write a book. And they really said, you can't continue under a pseudonym. You need to put your name on it to give yourself credibility. They need to know you actually do have a qualification. There is credibility behind these drawings.
这些画作背后有科学、理论和培训作为支撑。所以如果我们要做一本书，你确实需要把你的名字放上去。所以我不情愿地加上了我的名字，并将我的账号从“心理学妈妈”解除了匿名。这就是事情的经过。太棒了。我的意思是，是的，艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特。这难道不讽刺吗？
There is kind of, you know, science, theory, training behind these drawings. So if we're going to do a book, you do need to put your name on it. So reluctantly, I then added my name to as well. and de-anonymised my account from being the psychology mum. So that's how it all came around. Amazing. I mean, yeah, Alanis Morissette. And isn't it ironic?
嗯，你可以想象我和我丈夫之间的短信。艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特关注了我。发短信给麦克。这难道不讽刺吗？我对此的对应是，我崇拜杰里米·瓦恩（Jeremy Vine），他现在在Instagram上关注了我，我就想，太爱了。太爱了。太爱杰里米了。但是，是的，有没有哪一幅特定的画是关键性的，是真正引发滚雪球效应的那一幅？还是它们几乎是同时火起来的？因为疫情的完美风暴，每个人手里都有手机。是的，我的意思是，我认为在此之前它们就被大量转发了。所以最初引发这一切的画是“容量杯”，它基本上是一种非常简化、日常化的压力桶概念，
Well, you can imagine the text messaging between me and my husband. Alanis Morissette has followed me. Text Mac. Isn't that ironic? My equivalent of that is that I adore Jeremy Vine and he follows me on Instagram now and I'm like, Love it. Love it. Love Jeremy. But yeah, was there like one particular drawing that was pivotal, which was the one that really started the snowballing? Or did they all sort of take off at the same time? Because of the perfect storm of the pandemic and everyone having their phones in their hands. Yeah, I mean, I think beforehand they were being shared lots. So the original drawing that started at all was the capacity cup, which is basically a kind of really simplified everyday version of the stress.
但让它变得如此简单。这始于脑损伤小组，当时我试图解释我们如何拥有有限的容量，以及为什么有时它会溢出。我实际上只是从桌子上拿起一个杯子。我说，这就像一个杯子。我们旧的咖啡杯。这就像一个杯子。想象一下它正在变满，但你已经达到了满负荷。然后把它倒出来，它成了小组的一部分。然后把它画得稍微好看一点，稍微多彩一点，不使用NHS的圆珠笔。所以即使在疫情之前，它也成为了人们显然会参与、理解并产生共鸣的概念。所以即使在疫情之前，内容也被大量转发。所以那可能是其中之一，我不知道它是否是我画的第一幅，
bucket, but making it so simple. And that started from the brain injury group where I was trying to explain how we have limited capacity and why sometimes it overflows. And I actually just picked up from a table. I said, it's like a cup. We old coffee cups. It's like a cup. And just imagine it's getting full, but you're a full capacity. Then through it out, it became part of the group. And then through it out slightly nicer, slightly more colourful, not using NHS viral pens. So that even before the pandemic became, you know, was something that people obviously engaged with and got the concept and just understood and clicked with them. And so even before the pandemic, things were being shared lots. So that was probably one which started, I don't know if it was the first time I drew,
但它确实开启了很多东西。然后在疫情期间，我想我所做的一切，真的，人们只是，我想它是在为人们理清思路。它在帮助人们理解他们正在经历的事情，因为我们中没有人经历过这种情况。我们都在试图弄清楚它。这是一个奇怪的新世界。我想我所做的是双重的。我吸收了我听到的经历，但我也在Instagram上与人们一起做这些事。所以我说，我正在做这幅画。
but it certainly started a lot of it. And then in the pandemic, I'd say everything I did, really, people were just, it was making, I think it was making sense of it for people. It was helping people understand what they were experiencing because none of us had experienced it before. We were all trying to make sense of it. It was a bizarre new world. And what I was doing, I guess it was twofold. I was taking experiences I'd heard, but also I was doing them with people on Instagram. So I'd say, I'm doing this drawing.
我放了一个什么都没有的杯子。但标题，我说，你会把什么放进去？所以这几乎就像是一个主题分析。人们会把他们的回复发给我，我会对它们进行分类，没有任何可以被识别的内容，但我会把它们分类，然后放进画里。所以这是一种集体体验，
I put up a cup without anything in it. But the kind of titles, I said, what would you put in here? So it was almost like a thematic analysis. People would send their responses to me and I'd theme them, nothing that could be identified, but I'd theme them and then put them into the drawing. So it was kind of a collective experience,
不仅仅是我的经历，不仅仅是人们看到的经历，而是集体体验，然后把它们放上去。所以我说几乎每一篇帖子都只是，你知道，它只是，是的，有点失控了。但这让它对人们来说非常有验证感，这就是为什么它真的引起了共鸣，不是吗？这就是那种共同所有权，是的，我在“心理学妈妈”的作品中看到了自己，我觉得她实际上是在对我说话，在某些情况下也是在为我说话。有了那种共同所有权。听起来确实是一些非常非常强大的东西。疫情期间你多久发布一次内容？哦，天哪。我的意思是，我没有任何社交媒体计划。我从来没有过社交媒体计划。
not just my experience, not just people had scenes experience, but collective experience and then put those up. So I'd say just about every post was just, you know, it was just, yeah, just going a little bit out of control. But then that makes it so, you know, validating for people, which is why it was really resonating, doesn't it? And it's that co-ownership that, yes, I see myself in the work of the psychology
所以当我有机会时，它是零星的。当我的孩子们通常睡觉时，我会坐下来做。但我也发现这在个人层面上非常放松。我一直很有创造力。所以画画在当时确实是我放松的方式。也理清了我自己在疫情期间在员工福利部门工作的经历。所以它是零星的。
mum, and I feel like she's actually speaking to me and in some cases for me as well. with that co-ownership. Sounds like some really powerful, powerful stuff to have done. How often were you posting during the pandemic? Oh gosh. I mean, I have no social media plan. I have never had a social media plan.
我可能一周发布三四次，下一次什么都没有，因为我有更多的事情要做。没有明确的计划。我记得人们联系我说，你的社交媒体策略是什么？我说，找到我有空的时间。这就是我的社交媒体策略，你知道，我选择在我想做的时候做这件事很好，
So it was erratic when I had the chance. When my children were usually in bed, I was sit and do it. But I was also finding it personally very relaxing. I've always been quite creative. So drawing was really at that point my way to switch off. And also makes sense of my own experiences and working, you know, in a staff well-being during the pandemic. So it was erratic.
但也可能让它在长期来看作为一种开始变得难以管理。增长。是的，我想即使对我自己来说，作为一名创作者和心理学家，我需要一个工作计划。我需要知道，例如，我什么时候要录制播客，什么时候有时间看剪辑，什么时候有时间考虑缩略图等等。因为这些事情不会凭空发生。我认为当我们没有那种结构时，我们往往会承担更多，
I could post maybe three, four times one week and the next time nothing, because I had far more on. There was no clear plan. And I remember people getting touched with me saying, what's your social media strategy? I was like, find the time when I can. That's my social media strategy, which, you know, it was nice that I just chose to do it when I wanted to,
这我想最终导致我们自己的内在资源变薄，这随后引导我们走向倦怠的概念和现实，这当然也是我们今天要讨论的内容，因为你有一本关于倦怠的新书。但在我们谈到那个之前，当你创作你的第一本“书宝宝”时，那是什么感觉？那一切进展如何？那是在疫情爆发之前。所以我实际上是在20年1月到3月写的。
but also probably made it on the manageable longer term as a start. to grow. Yeah, I think even for myself, speaking as a creator and a psychologist at the same time, I need a job plan. I need to know, for example, when I'm going to record podcasts, when I'm going to have time to watch the edits, when I'm going to have time to think about thumbnails and all of that jazz. Because this stuff isn't just going to happen by magic. I think when we don't have that structure, then we can often pick up the slack,
我交了，我想，最终稿。我的意思是，有多次迭代要求，你知道，但其中一份最终稿。就在2020年3月，我们谈论封锁的时候。我在书中提到的一件事是，在我的，你知道，最近的疫情中，因为这本书要在9月出版。我记得当时想，我应该说这个吗？我们不知道这会走向何方。编辑，他非常棒，说，嗯，我想我们也许不应该强调
which I guess ultimately contributes to our own inner resources running thin, which then heads us towards the concept and the reality of burnout, which is of course what we're going to be talking about today as well, because you've got a new book looking at burnout. But before we get to that, what was it like then when you were creating your first book baby? Like, how did that all go? So that was just before the pandemic hit. So I actually wrote it from January to March, 20.
这一点太多，因为它在9月书出版时可能就结束了。我想我们当时都是这样想的。所以我的意思是，我记得它，你知道，我有一个非常受限的时期来做这件事，并且真的很享受。这真的，你知道，是一件非常令人兴奋的事情，你知道，把它从在线格式转化为书面格式，并围绕心理学做一些有创意的事情。而且这，你知道，本质上是令人兴奋的。所以这是一个，你知道，一个愉快的整理过程。当然，就在交稿时，封锁开始了，整个事情，你知道，整个疫情开始了，这比我们任何人预期的都要长得多。
And I handed in, I think, the final draft. I mean, there's multiple iterations asked, you know, but one of the final drafts. Just as the kind of March 2020, we were talking about locking down. And one of the things I'd said in it was in my, you know, in the recent pandemic, because the book was coming out in September. And I remember at the time thinking, oh, should I be saying this? We don't know where this is going. And the editor, who was fantastic, saying, well, I think we shouldn't maybe emphasize
所以到2020年9月书出版时，我想我们正要进入下一次封锁。你知道我们当时对时间线有多困惑，因为时间变得模糊而奇怪。而且，我在苏格兰。所以我们的封锁时间线与英格兰略有不同，与其他国家也不同。但我记得我们要么还在封锁中，要么即将进入另一次封锁。所以它变成了很多在线工作、录音、在线事物。实际上，设置这个很有趣，因为我已经有一段时间没做这个了，
this too much because it'll be it probably be over by the time the book comes out in September. And I think that's how we were all thinking. So I mean, I remember it, you know, I had a really kind of contained period to do it and really enjoyed doing it. It was really, you know, something that was really exciting, you know, taking it from an online format into a written format and doing something creative around psychology. And that's, you know, inherently exciting. So it was a, you know, an enjoyable process putting it together. And of course, just the hands in, you know, the lockdowns hit, the whole thing, you know, the whole pandemic started, which went on for much longer than any of us could have anticipated.
因为这实际上给了我那个时候的闪回，你知道，在线做事情。所以作为作者我以为会发生的所有事情，你去参加活动，在书店看到我的书，都没有发生。我对此没有经验。所以一切都是在线的，一切都是数字化的，是的。所以这是一个有趣的经历，但写第一本书是一个非常愉快的经历，我认为，你知道，在临床心理学培训中，这不一定是你会想做的事情。所以对我来说做这件事非常令人兴奋。好吧，祝贺你。我希望你此后已经在书店的书架上看到了你的第一本“书宝宝”。是的，我有过多次。我仍然，
So by the time the book came out to September 2020, I think we were just about to go into the next lockdown. You know how we all get confused about the timelines roundabout then because time became blurred and strange. And also, I'm in Scotland. So our timelines for lockdowns for lockdowns. were slightly different to England, which were different to other countries. But I remember that we were either still in lockdown or about to go into another lockdown. So it became a lot of online work, recordings, things online. Actually, it's funny setting this up because I haven't done this for a while
我实际上几天前发了帖子，因为我在爱丁堡。我在一家大店里看到了我的两本书。我仍然感到兴奋。看到它绝对是一种快感。我不知道这是因为我很久没看到了。还是也许只是因为它仍然有一些东西，比如，哦，我是个作家。这很令人兴奋。是的，我每次还是会拍照，我的手机里有很多我的书在书店的照片，
because this was actually giving me flashbacks to that time of, you know, doing things online. So all the things I thought would happen as an author, you go into events, see my book, in a bookshop just didn't happen. I had no experience of that. So it was all online and all digital and yes. So it was an interesting experience, but a very enjoyable experience right in the first book, which is something I think, you know, in clinical psychology training, it's not necessarily something you think you will do. So it was very exciting for me to be doing that. Well, congratulations on that. And I hope that you've since seen your first book baby on a, on a shelf in a bookshop. Yeah, I have a multiple occasions. And I still,
这非常非常不酷。当我这样做时，我的孩子们认为这很不酷。我不认为这不酷，我完全理解。我喜欢它。多做点。做吧。我建议你每次看到它都继续这样做。当然，你知道，你的第一本“书宝宝”不是你唯一的“书宝宝”。其他人很快就跟进了，不是吗？所以是的，然后我在三年内写了三本书。所以第一本，《现代生活工具包》，于2020年9月出版。然后2020年9月。一，《幸福工具包》。然后三部曲的完成篇原定于2022年9月出版。但我推迟了一点，因为我有很多事情要做。它于2023年1月出版。
And I actually posted a couple of days ago because I was down in Edinburgh. And I saw two of my books in a big shop. And I still get a thrill. An absolute thrill of seeing it. And I don't know if that's because I didn't see it for so long. Or maybe it's just because it still has some things like, oh, I'm an author. That's quite exciting. Yes, I still take a photo every time and I have lots of photos on my phone of my book in a book shop,
所以《情绪工具包》，三部曲的完成篇。就是这样。太棒了。所以在你心中，它一直打算成为三部曲吗？不。不，它不是。它不打算成为三部曲。它，我不知道在第一本之后我是否会写任何其他书。
which is very, very uncool. And my kids think it's very uncool when I do it. I don't think it's uncool and I totally get it. I love it. Do it more. Do it. Continue to do it every time you see it, I would say. And of course, you know, your first book baby is not your only book baby. Others followed quite quickly, didn't they? So then, yes, then I wrote three books in three years. So the first one, a toolkit for modern life, came out in September 2020. And then September 2020. one, a toolkit for happiness. And then the completion of the trilogy was due to come out in September 2022. But I delayed it a bit just because I had a lot going on. And it came out in January, 2023.
我认为作为作者是不可预测的。你不知道，特别是当你对出版业了解不多时。我不知道会发生什么，但后来与出版商决定了。我们要写同一个系列的三本。可爱。好吧，它们是可爱的书。现在我们在这里谈论，你知道，你当然，还有你的第四本“书宝宝”。现在我们已经了解了一点关于旋风之旅，
So a toolkit for your emotions, the completion of the trilogy. There we go. Amazing. So in your mind, it was always going to be a trilogy? No. No, it wasn't. It wasn't going to be a trilogy. It was, I didn't know if I was going to write any other books after the first one.
感觉很有道理，因为实际上这本书是关于倦怠的，它确实受到你自己的倦怠故事的启发，以及它是如何产生的，以及你如何学会再次茁壮成长。你能引导我们了解一下吗，艾玛？不幸的是，我不能给你看这本书，因为它已经被印刷了，或者它已经被印刷了，我正在等待副本，
I think it is unpredictable as an author. You don't know, particularly when you don't know much about the publishing industry. I didn't know what was going to happen, but then after that it was decided with the publisher. We were going to write three in the same series. Lovely. Well, they are lovely books. And now we are here talking about, you know, you of course, but also your fourth book, baby. which now we've kind of learned a bit about the whistle stop tour,
但我可以给你看封面上的小人物。所以这是封面上的火焰，它从完全点燃、兴奋、充满活力开始。如果我们把它转过来，它就变成了精疲力竭。里面还有一个小脸。然而，我现在已经度过了那个阶段，回到了我的火焰，再次被点燃。
kind of makes a lot of sense, because actually the book is about burnout, and it's really inspired by your own tale of burnout and how that came about and how you kind of have learned to thrive again. Could you guide us through that a little bit, Emma? Unfortunately, I can't show you the book because it has been printed or it has been printed, and I'm awaiting copies,
所以这确实是故事。这就是启发这本书的原因。所以不像我之前的书，里面有一点个人信息，但非常非常少。这是一本稍微不同的书，因为不仅是关于倦怠的心理学理论、背后的科学、支持你走出倦怠的治疗技能和工具，以及防止你首先进入倦怠。它也，如你所知，贯穿了我的故事。
but I can show your little figure from the front cover. So this is the flame from the front cover, which goes from being fully lit, excited, energetic. If we turn it round, and it turns to burnt out. There's a little face in there too. However, I am now through that stage, and back to my flame, being lit again.
是什么导致我精疲力竭？当我精疲力竭时什么帮助了我，当我精疲力竭时什么没有帮助我，以及什么帮助我恢复了。谢谢。是的，有时我认为当我们确实融入我们自己的个人故事时，我们可以以更多的信念和更多的共鸣讲述一个故事，真的。
So this really is the story. This is what inspired the book. So unlike my previous books, where there was a little bit of personal information in them, but very, very small amounts. This is a slightly different book because not only is about the psychological theory of burnout, the science behind it, the therapeutic skills and tools to support you getting out of burnout, but also stopping you getting into burnout in the first place. It also, as you know, has my story woven through it.
它确实显示了我们更加可信，因为我们拥有专业和个人的见解。所以当然，你知道，虽然他们说，你不必，你知道，被公共汽车撞到才知道它疼，它确实有助于同理心。谢谢。我有点记得我在书中读到的东西，感觉非常强大，关于一件本应该非常有趣的事情。实际上，在生活中资源更充足的时候，艾玛可能真的会觉得它很有趣。
So what led me to burning out? what helped you when I was burnt out, what didn't help me when I was burned out, and what helped me to recover. Thank you. And yeah, sometimes I think we can tell a story with more conviction and with more resonance when we do weave in our own personal story, really.
但那是你和朋友们的周末旅行，它真的实现了。你介意引导我们了解那个故事吗，艾玛？我想我可能已经精疲力竭了一段时间，但我是一个非常忙碌的人。我在NHS工作，我在写书，我在育儿，还在做很多其他事情。我有一种应对方式，这在我的一生中对我有效，那就是坚持下去，坚持到底。只要坚持到最后，把它做完，然后你就可以放松了。所以我坚持下去，坚持，不断地完成下一件事和下一件事。但事情在急剧增加。
And it kind of really shows that we are even more credible because we've got the professional and the personal insights. So of course, you know, whilst they say it, you don't have to, you know, be hit by a bus to know it hurts, it sure does help with the empathy. Thank you. And I'm kind of remembering something I read in the book, which felt like really quite powerful about something that should have been kind of really fun. And actually Emma on a more resourced time in her life might have found it really fun.
所以我可能，嗯，我已经精疲力竭了一段时间，回顾过去，这在事后看来非常明显。但我的朋友们，我通常会在一月、二月左右安排一次旅行。这一次，我想还有限制。所以我们决定去爱丁堡，美丽的城市。强烈推荐任何人去爱丁堡。这是一个绝对令人惊叹的城市。这些也是我最老的朋友，也是心理学专业的，你知道，关心、善良、热情的人。我犹豫是否应该去，因为我知道我精疲力竭了。
But it was a weekend away with your friends where it really came to fruition. Would you mind guiding us through that story, Emma? I guess I'd probably been burned out for a while, but I'm a very busy person. I was working in the NHS, I was writing books, I was parenting and doing lots of other things. And I have a coping style, which has worked for me throughout my life of keeping on going and persevering. Just get to the end of this, get it done, and then you can relax. So I kept on going, persevering, kept on getting through the next thing and the next thing. But the things were increasing hugely.
我想，我会从中受益吗？还是我会享受它？但还有一个问题是我能为此做出贡献吗？因为，你知道，我现在感觉不像我自己。我觉得我失去了幽默感。我觉得我不是我，不是我通常的样子。所以，你知道，我会是，你知道，他们不会得到通常那样的艾玛。所以我丈夫说，看，你知道，这是一件很棒的事情。
So I'd probably be, well, I had been burnt out for a while and it's very obvious in hindsight looking back. But my friends, I may usually arrange a trip around about January, February in the year. And this time, I think there were still restrictions. So we decided to go to Edinburgh, beautiful city. Highly recommend for anybody to go to Edinburgh. It's absolutely stunning city. And these are some of my oldest friends also from psychology degrees, you know, caring, kind, passionate people. And I debated whether I should go because I knew I was exhausted.
你喜欢去看他们。你喜欢和他们一起出去。所以去吧。我说去吧。我说去吧。你知道，你是对的。我们走吧。所以我确实去了。在很多方面，这是一个可爱的周末。
And I thought, will I benefit from this or not? Or will I enjoy it? But also there was an element of can I contribute to this or not? Because, you know, I don't feel like myself right now. I feel like I've lost my sense of humour. I feel like I'm not quite me and not Emma that I normally am. so, you know, will I be, you know, they're not going to be getting Emma as she normally is. So my husband said, look, you know, it's a great thing.
但它也是，你知道，做一些我有一段时间没做的事情。所以出去社交。因为疫情，我们很长一段时间都没有这样做。但晚上出去社交。喝酒，我们出去吃饭，在美丽的爱丁堡城市走很多路去看看。总的来说，这本应该是一个非常非常美丽、愉快的周末。然后我们出去的第一天晚上，我们吃了一顿美餐，第二天我们在城市里漫步。第三天我们决定，或者第二天晚上，抱歉，我们决定留在，在，我们有一个美丽的
You love going to see them. You love going away with them. So just go. I said go. I said go. You know, you're right. Let's go. So I did go. And it was a lovely weekend in many ways.
爱丁堡的公寓，我们决定留在家里，喝几杯，聊聊天。我们正在聊天。然后似乎毫无征兆地，我站起来离开了房间。我们一直在，我甚至不记得我们在谈论什么。那是一些非常无害的事情，你知道，相当有趣的谈话。但有什么东西击中了我的心。我站起来离开了房间。
But it was also, you know, doing things that hadn't been doing much for a while. So going out socialising. None of us had been doing for a long time because of the pandemic. But going out socialising a night. drinking, we're out for meals, walking lots around the beautiful city of Edinburgh to have a look. In general, it should have been a really, really beautiful, pleasant weekend. And then the first night we went out, we had a nice meal, the second day we wandered around the city. The third day we decided, or the second night, sorry, we decided to stay at, in the, we had a beautiful
我的朋友们有点像，你在做什么？我也在想，我在做什么？我只是开始颤抖。实际上，我在书中描述的方式，它表面上是一种休克反应，但没有什么可休克的。关于。但显然，我想，你知道，发生了什么是我剩下的资源太少了。这只是把我推向了边缘。就像我的容量杯满了。我剩下的水平太少了。我快要溢出了。而且，你知道，在人们的陪伴下已经两天了
flat in Edinburgh and we decided to stay at home and just have a few drinks and a chat. And we're having a chat. And then out of seemingly nowhere, I got up and left the room. And we've been, I can't even remember what we've been talking about. It was something really innocuous, you know, quite interesting conversation. But something just hit me. And I got up and left the room.
现在，走很多路，喝酒，累了。对我来说可能也没有我自己的空间，因为我喜欢有我自己的空间，所有这些微小的事情，否则会非常愉快，只是把我推向了边缘。我想这是我的身体在说，艾玛，停下来。你需要停下来。停止忽视我。
And my friends were kind of like, what's you doing? And I was also thinking, what am I doing? And I just started shaking. It was effectively, the way I described in the book, it was ostensibly a shock reaction with nothing to be shocked. about. But obviously, I think, you know, what had been happening is I had so little resources left. And this is just pushing me over the edge. It's like my capacity cup was full. And I had so little level left. I was about to overflow. And having been, you know, in people's company for two
你忽视我太久了。你不能再忽视我了。所以这就是，本应该在爱丁堡度过的美好周末变成了我当时想，好吧，我们需要在这里采取一些行动。需要发生点什么。是的，绝对。这让我想起当我还是职业生涯早期的心理学家时，我正在和老年人一起工作，他们中的许多人会谈论经历过
days now, walking lots, drinking, tired. Also probably for me not having my own space, because I like having my own space, all this tiny little things, which otherwise would have been really enjoyable, just pushed me over the edge. And I guess it was my body saying, Emma, stop. You need to stop. Stop ignoring me.
崩溃，这确实引导我思考，那是什么？直到我的职业生涯进展，我才想，我似乎找不到崩溃的诊断。就像它，它似乎不是一回事，但我意识到实际上倦怠现在在ICD-11中，我想我没说错，作为一种职业综合症。但是当然，倦怠可以存在于，你知道，我们所有的角色中。你知道，我是一位母亲。我经营一家企业。我是一位妻子。你知道，我是一位创作者。所以，你知道，你可以在你生活的许多领域精疲力竭，不仅仅是在，不仅仅是在你的职业中。是的，我只是，我知道有，我不认为有一个答案，这甚至不是一个问题。这只是一个观察，实际上我们现在正在走向理解
You've been ignoring me for too long. You can't ignore me anymore. So that was the, what should have been a wonderful weekend in Edinburgh became the point where I was like, okay, we need some action here. something needs to happen. Yeah, absolutely. It's making me think about when I was an early career psychologist myself and I was working with older adults, many of them would talk about having had
这个更多。当我们更理解它时，我们可以更多地验证人们，我们可以帮助他们理解如何，我想，最终，黄金标准预防。但是，你知道，如果它已经发生了，如何让轮子重新转动，并以一种去羞耻化、赋予人们力量的方式去做。并做你用你可爱的火柴人向我们展示的事情，也就是，你知道，重新获得力量、成就、满足感和享受。生活，这样你的火焰又重新发光了。是的，我认为这非常有趣，因为我也考虑过崩溃这个词。我在整个职业生涯中都考虑过这一点。我认为通常我们将它应用于当我们不确定发生了什么时的情况，并试图理清它。但我认为它也喂养
a breakdown and really that led me to think, well, what is that? And it was only as my career progressed that I thought, I can't seem to find like a diagnosis of a breakdown. Like it, it doesn't seem to be a thing, but I'm aware that actually burnout is now in the ICD-11, I think I'm right in saying as an occupational kind of syndrome. But of course, burnout can go among, you know, all of our roles. You know, I'm a mother. I run a business. I'm a wife. You know, I'm a creator. And so, you know, you can burn out in many areas of your life, not just in, not just in your occupational. And yeah, I just, I know there's, I don't think there is an answer to, this isn't even any of a question. It's just an observation that actually we are now moving towards understanding
进入其他东西，这对倦怠非常关键，那就是羞耻。你知道，我认为通常我们将这些事情内化为关于我们自己的事情。我认为同样可以应用于崩溃这个词。你知道，发生了什么。我崩溃了。这周围可能有一种羞耻感。作为临床心理学家，我对此并不免疫。事实上，我认为几乎有一层额外的羞耻感，你带着心理健康专业人士的身份。
this more. And when we understand it more, We can validate people more and we can help them understand how to, I guess, ultimately, a gold standard prevented. But, you know, if it has happened, how to get the wheels back on and to do so in a way that de-shames people, empowers them. And does what you've shown us with your lovely matchman, which is to, you know, to regain power, achievement, sense of satisfaction and enjoyment. of life so that your flame is back aglow. Yeah, I think that's very interesting because I also kind of consider what is the term breakdown. I've considered that throughout my career. And I think often we apply it to circumstances when we're not sure what's going on and to try and make sense of it. But I also think it feeds
因为你不仅有正常的社会羞耻感，这是来自，我知道这来自哪里，几千年来关于情绪以及它们如何在心理健康中运作的信仰，我们真的需要改变。这多年来一直是我们的工作，作为临床心理学家，试图用背后的科学真正更新这些信仰。但我然后认为有一层额外的羞耻感。就像，但我是一名临床心理学家。我写关于这个的书。
into something else, which is really critical for burnout, which is around shame. You know, I think often we internalise these things as being something about us. And And I think the same can be applied to the term breakdown. You know, something's happening. I have broken down. And there can be a degree of shame around that. And as a clinical psychologist, I'm not immune to that. In fact, I think there's almost an extra layer of shame that you come with a mental health professional.
我告诉人们关于这个。然而它还是发生了。现在，在智力层面上，我绝对知道没有什么可羞耻的。有，你知道，我从根本上相信任何人都可以经历心理健康困难，事实上，大多数人都会。所以大多数人，你知道，事实上，研究表明，在你的一生中保持心理健康比经历糟糕的心理健康要罕见得多。所以你一生中某个时候的糟糕心理健康是常态。
Because not only do you have the normal societal shame, which is from, and I know where this comes from, thousands of years of beliefs about emotions and how they operate in mental health, which we really need to shift. and that's been our work, you know, for many years as clinical psychologist, trying to really update these beliefs with the science behind it. But I then think there's an extra layer of shame. And it's like, but I'm a clinical psychologist. I write books about this.
这对任何人来说都不应该感到惊讶，因为糟糕的身体健康是常态。我们是否将这两者分开仍然是某事。我们需要在未来几年科学地看待。所以这对任何人来说都不应该感到惊讶。但你可以理论上知道某事，你可以感觉非常不同，因为，你知道，所有那些几千年来关于心理健康、情绪的信仰，它们仍然影响着你，尽管理论上知道它。所以我认为，我能在书中谈论这个吗？书中几乎有一个羞耻叙述者，我称之为羞耻，想法是将它从你自己身上外化。羞耻，
I tell people about this. And yet it still happened. Now, on an intellectual level, I absolutely know that there's nothing to be ashamed about. There is, you know, I fundamentally believe that anybody can experience mental health difficulties, and in fact, most people do. So most people, you know, and in fact, the research suggests that it's much rarer to stay mentally well throughout your life than experience poor mental health. So poor mental health at some point in your life is the norm.
对我说，你有什么权利告诉人们这个？你自己并没有完全做到。这是一种额外的羞耻感。就像你是一名支持心理健康的临床心理学家，写关于心理健康的书。这是你所做工作的核心。但是是的，你没有做到。而且我，但我认为，你知道，我会对别人说什么？这就是生活。你知道，这些事情发生是因为人、环境和他们正在经历的一切的复杂组合。所以你必须退后一步，思考是什么导致了这一点。保持好奇而不是羞耻。
That should be no surprise to anybody because poor physical health is the norm. And whether we separate these two is still something. we need to scientific we'll look at in future years. So that should be no surprise to anybody. But you can know something theoretically and you can feel something very differently because, you know, all those thousands of years about beliefs about mental health, emotions, they still impact on you despite knowing it theoretically. So I think, can I speak about this in the book? There's almost a, there's in fact a shame narrator throughout the book who I call shame and the idea is to externalise it from yourself. And shame,
停下来思考，是什么导致了这一点？我需要承认哪些因素是我无法控制的？哪些因素我可以做点什么？哪些因素我，哪些因素承认我实际上无法改变它？这确实是我走上那段旅程的原因，退后一步，看到，是的，羞耻在告诉我这个。羞耻或羞耻对每个人说话，特别是当我们的资源不足时，
says to me, what right do you have to tell people about this? You didn't exactly do it yourself. And that's an extra layer of shame. It's like you're a clinical psychologist who supports mental health, who writes books about mental health. This is at the heart of what you do. But yeah, you didn't do it. And I, but I think, you know, what would I say to somebody else? That's life. You know, these things happen because a complex mix of persons. context and everything that's going on for them. So you have to draw back and think what did lead to this. Be curious rather than shameful.
当我们的资源耗尽时，它们进入负面过载。所以我把它描述为负面忍者接管。负面忍者接管你的大脑，他们在踢你的大脑，他们在用力推。所以当你感到耗尽时，覆盖这一点要困难得多。
Stop and think, what contributed to this? Which elements do I need to recognise as things which I couldn't control? Which elements can I do something about? Which elements have I, which elements kind of recognise that I can't actually shift that? And that's really kind of what led me down that journey and stepping back and seeing, yeah, Shane's telling me this. Shane or shame speaks to everybody and particularly when our resources are low,
但这确实是关于退后一步，说这只是一个正常的人类体验，作为临床心理学家可能确实给你一些额外的保护，我猜，在某种程度上，因为你确实有支持你生活的理论和知识。我确实把这些放在了适当的位置。但仍然会有导致，你知道，它影响你的人和环境的组合。这将是，你知道，如果我们不这样做，我们就是机器人。是的，绝对。
when our resources are depleted, they go into negativity overloads. So I describe it as a negative ninja takeover. The negative ninja is take over your brain, they're kicking at your brain, they're pushing hard. So it's much harder to override that when you are feeling depleted.
这就是我说话时的想法。我认为我们总是需要赋予自己力量，让自己首先成为人类。是的，绝对。所以当然，你以“心理学妈妈”的身份开始了你的旅程，你知道，手里拿着一支笔。我理解对吗，你的新书里有图表、画作、插图？是的，绝对。这就是我的大脑工作的方式。它视觉化地工作。我喜欢通过视觉效果让概念变得生动。所以最初这本书里不会有插图，但后来我发现无法把它们排除在外。
But it is really about stepping back and saying this is just a normal human experience and being a clinical psychologist probably does give you some extra protection about that, I guess, and some way because you do have the theory and knowledge that supports you in your life. And I do put those in place. But yet there still will be mixes of person context that lead to, you know, it impacts on you. It would be, you know, we would be robots if it didn't. Yeah, absolutely.
我正在视觉化这看起来像什么，所以我们同意这本书里会有一些图像。与之前的书略有不同的是它是黑白的。这对我来说是一个全新的学习过程，尝试用黑白画东西。所以这本书里有视觉效果，因为这就是我临床上一直运作的方式，也是我在书中一直运作的方式。
And that was kind of my thinking as you were speaking where. that I think we always need to empower ourselves to allow ourselves to be humans first. Yeah, absolutely. So of course you started off your journey as the psychology mum with, you know, with a pen in your hand. Am I right in thinking that there are diagrams, there are drawings, illustrations in your new book? Yes, absolutely. So that's how my brain works. It works visually. I like to bring concepts to life through visuals. So initially there weren't going to be illustrations in this book, but then I found it impossible to keep them out.
我只是认为它真的有助于让概念变得生动。当你试图录制有声书时，这带来了一些挑战，就像我过去两天一直在做的那样。但我每本书都这样做，所以我有贯穿全书的角色，这几乎让心理学概念变得生动。所以你看到了火柴人。那是倦怠的代表，但你可以再次重新点燃你的火。每本书中出现的经典角色是我的小大脑角色，所以布莱恩大脑。所以这是，代表你的大脑，因为我真的相信理解你的大脑以及它是如何工作的，理解，你知道，那种偏见，
I was visualising what this looked like, so we agreed that there would be some images in this book. The slight difference to the previous books is it is black and white. That was a whole new learning process for me, trying to draw things in black and white. So there are visuals in this book because that's how I've always operated clinically and how I always operate in my books.
发生的事情以及为什么这些事情在脑功能方面发生在我们身上可以真正帮助去羞耻或去污名化，并帮助你理解，你知道，你的人类体验。所以布莱恩大脑出现在每一本书中。在这本书中，他出现是为了介绍一系列反思。所以反思你，好的，你读了
I just think it really helps bring the concepts to life. poses a bit of a challenge when you're trying to record the audio book, as I have been doing the last two days. But what I do in each book, so I have characters that go through the book, which almost bring psychological concepts to life. So you've seen the match. That's the representation of burnout, but you can relight your fire again. The classic one who appears in every book is my little brain character, so Brian the Brain. So this is, represents your brain because I really believe that understanding your brain and how it works, understanding, you know, the kind of biases,
这个内容，但这如何应用于你？你对此有什么想法？所以他引导我们读这本书。然后还有一些其他角色我可以介绍。所以关于爱丁堡的故事，表面上什么都没发生，把我推向了边缘。但它是什么，如果你看这里，是一个微小的东西。所以这是微小的东西。所以微小的东西是让你不知所措或你的容量溢出的东西。我描述说，如果你不是80后和90后的孩子，你可能不理解这一点。所以向那些不是的人道歉。你可能必须谷歌一下。我把它描述为微小的东西是让你容量杯溢出到克雷莫拉泡沫土地的东西。你知道什么是克雷莫拉泡沫吗？不，好的。我确定按年龄在这里。
the things that go on and why these things happen to us in terms of brain functioning can really help de-shame or de-stigmatise and help you understand kind of your human experience. So Brian the brain appears in every single book. And in this book, he appears to introduce a set of reflections. So reflections of you've, okay, you've read
了解大脑运作方式以及这些事情为何发生在我们身上，真的有助于消除羞耻感或污名化，并帮助你理解自己的人类体验。所以大脑布莱恩出现在每一本书中。在这一本书里，他负责引入一系列反思。也就是当你读完这些内容后，你会有什么反思？
this content, but how does that apply to you? What's your thoughts around this? So he guides us through the book. And then there are some other characters I can introduce. So my story about Edinburgh, nothing ostensibly happened that threw me over the edge. But what it was, if you look here, was a teeny tiny thing. So this is the teeny tiny thing. So the teeny tiny thing is that thing which makes you overwhelmed or your capacity overflow. I describe it that you might not understand this if you're not a child of the 80s and the 90s. So apologies for those that aren't. You might have to Google it. I describe it as the teeny tiny thing is a thing that makes your capacity cut overflow into cremola foam land. Do you know what cremola foam is? No, okay. I'm sure by age here.
这些内容对你有什么启发？你对此有什么想法？所以他引导我们阅读整本书。此外，我还可以介绍其他一些角色。关于我在爱丁堡的故事，表面上并没有发生什么让我崩溃的大事。但如果你仔细看，其实是一件微不足道的小事。这就是那件微不足道的小事。所谓微不足道的小事，就是指那些让你感到不知所措或超出你承受能力的事情。我用一种方式来描述它，如果你不是80后或90后，可能不太理解，先向非此年龄段的人道歉，你们可能需要去谷歌搜索一下。我把这件微不足道的小事描述为让你承受能力溢出到Cremola Foam世界的东西。你知道什么是Cremola Foam吗？不知道，好吧。我相信在这里的年龄层应该知道。
So cremola foam was a drink from the 80s where you put some. powder into cup and you added water to it and you never got that quantity right. It all was overflowed. So the teeny tiny thing is a thing that your capacity is so full already and you might not notice it or your stress levels are so high is the tiny thing which pushes you into overwhelm land or Cremola foam capacity cup. So it's about recognising that thing in itself maybe is an issue because people can go, why did that happen? I mean it was a nothing but there's everything else that's going on underneath it that's creating the stress that's adding to your capacity that's already filling your cup to that level. I guess the modern kind of visualised image of that
Cremola foam是80年代的一种饮料，你把粉末倒进杯子里，加水，但你永远无法掌握好比例。它总是会溢出来。所以“微小事物”指的是你的容量已经满了，你可能没有注意到，或者你的压力水平太高了，以至于那件微小的事情把你推向了崩溃的边缘，或者说达到了Cremola foam杯子的容量极限。所以，关键在于认识到那件事本身可能只是个导火索，因为人们会问，为什么会发生这种情况？我的意思是，那只是一件小事，但在这之下还有其他一切正在发生的事情，它们正在制造压力，增加了你的负担，使你的杯子已经装满了。我想这大概是现代人对这种情况的一种形象化描述。
would be putting a mento in the in a Coke bottle, right? A tiny thing leads to a big reaction. If only had thought of that before I wrote the book, that would have been much more modern and talking to this generation. But I didn't. And some of the final pictures in the book are my little snail here. So this snail appears throughout the book and it's remembering that you can still achieve by slowing down. Actually, you will achieve more longer term
就像把曼妥思放进可乐瓶里一样，对吧？一件微小的事情导致了巨大的反应。如果我在写书之前想到这一点，那会更现代，也更符合这一代人的语境。但我没有。书中的一些最后插图是我的小蜗牛。这只蜗牛贯穿全书，它提醒你，通过放慢脚步，你仍然可以取得成就。事实上，从长远来看，你会取得更大的成就。
if you pause regularly and you don't need to rush constantly to get there. You don't need to always keep on and get the thing done. You don't need to go on to the end and finish it off. And finally, my little tortoise. So it was very, very cute. So the tortoise appears in the book too again, plodding along, not going very fast, and enjoying life, looking around them and seeing what's happening there, rather than just looking to the future and constantly leading on to the next thing on a treadmill. So these little characters appear throughout the book in the illustrations and exercises, which are designed to really help you apply the theory, the science, to your own situation.
如果你定期停下来，你不需要为了到达终点而不断奔波。你不需要总是马不停蹄地把事情做完。你不需要非得走到最后并把它完成。最后是我的小乌龟。它非常非常可爱。所以乌龟也出现在书中，它慢吞吞地走着，走得不快，享受着生活，环顾四周，观察着周围发生的事情，而不是只盯着未来，像在跑步机上一样不断地奔向下一件事。因此，这些小角色出现在书中的插图和练习中，旨在真正帮助你将理论和科学应用到你自己的情况中。
amazing and I think yeah that's when you've got something that you can visualize or that you can hold in mind visually I think it can be so powerful in helping those concepts to develop and I love that I love your story that actually this emerged originally in clinical practice and you saw that it really did seem to make a difference for actual clients and you were like I think I think we can do more here it's the true consultation model of psychology right like why do it? for one if you can do it for many. Emma, it sounds amazing. Who would you recommend this book is for? What sort of age? Are we talking adults here? Well, initially my books were published with the intention of using them with adults. But what I do know, and so yes, the book is for adults.
太棒了，我认为是的，当你拥有可以形象化或在脑海中视觉化呈现的东西时，我认为它在帮助这些概念发展方面会非常强大。我喜欢你的故事，实际上这最初是在临床实践中出现的，你看到它确实对实际的客户产生了影响，然后你觉得，我想我们在这里可以做得更多。这就是心理学真正的咨询模式，对吧？如果能帮助更多人，为什么要只帮助一个人呢？Emma，这听起来太棒了。你建议这本书适合谁看？什么年龄段？我们是在谈论成年人吗？嗯，最初我的书出版时是打算给成年人使用的。但我知道，所以是的，这本书是给成年人看的。
But what I do know is my books are used throughout schools, throughout, you know, primary schools, secondary schools, because children and teenagers engage with the visuals as well. And burnout is also, a elephant issue for adolescents. There's so much going on for them in the world. So I think the book could be used at any age, but might need adult facilitation to support with that, because I do know that teachers will build lessons around the book, lessons around the visuals. And I think this applies really nicely to this book as well. Okay, just before we have a think about where your books are available and when they're coming out and all of that stuff, I know that there was kind of a chapter that there just wasn't room for in your brand new book.
但我知道的是，我的书在学校里被广泛使用，在小学、中学里，因为儿童和青少年也能与这些视觉效果产生共鸣。倦怠也是青少年面临的一个巨大问题。他们在世界上经历的事情太多了。所以我认为这本书适合任何年龄段的人，但可能需要成年人的引导来提供支持，因为我知道老师们会围绕这本书设计课程，围绕这些视觉效果设计课程。我认为这也非常适用于这本书。好的，在我们考虑你的书在哪里可以买到、什么时候出版以及所有这些事情之前，我知道你的新书里有一章因为篇幅原因没能放进去。
And it was something that we chatted about just before we hit record. And the impact, I guess, of maybe being the psychology mum and kind of showing up and the pressures of social media and technology, you were like, oh, that's something I'm actually still really passionate about. Could you talk to us a little bit about that, Emma? Sure. So I wrote a whole chapter on technology and burnout. And it's really interesting because that's actually what I'm. research as well. So it's a topic that I'm really passionate about. And I wrote too much for the entire
那是我们在录音前聊到的话题。关于作为“心理学妈妈”的影响，以及在社交媒体和技术压力下展现自我的压力，你说过，哦，那是我仍然非常热衷的话题。你能跟我们聊聊那个吗，Emma？当然。我写了整整一章关于技术和倦怠的内容。这真的很有趣，因为那实际上也是我的研究方向。所以这是一个我非常热衷的话题。我写得太多了，超出了整本书的容量。
book. I wrote about 30,000 words far too much. I made myself a bigger job than I had to. So something had to go. And this was the obvious chapter that had to go. But it sat there and it felt uncomfortable with me because I think it's such an important topic. So what we decided to do is release it as a free e-book. So that is out there as a free e-book, which you will find via links on my page, or you can come over to my substack as well to find it and use that freely and download it. This was based on a further big question I should have mentioned previously. We released a free e-book during the pandemic to help people cope and that really was circulated all around the world. Ended up randomly with me meeting the Prime Minister,
我写了大约3万字，太多了。我给自己找了比必要更多的麻烦。所以必须删掉一些内容。而这一章显然是必须删掉的。但它放在那里，让我感到不舒服，因为我认为这是一个非常重要的话题。所以我们决定把它作为免费电子书发布。所以它现在作为免费电子书存在，你可以在我的页面上通过链接找到它，或者你也可以到我的Substack上找到它，免费使用并下载。这是基于我之前应该提到的另一个大问题。我们在疫情期间发布了一本免费电子书来帮助人们应对压力，那本书在世界各地流传。最后我竟然偶然遇见了首相，
which was very, very strange. Don't expect that to happen from this big, but hopefully it's of benefit to people because really my whole aim is to get stuff out there and get people to use it and improve their lives and for it to have an impact beneficially in their lives. So please come and find the free e-book around technology, social media and burnout. Amazing. What a brilliant and beautiful resource and what a great way of making sure that your work doesn't just kind of end up sitting in a filing cabinet somewhere. So well done to you and to your publishing team. So when people obviously are very keen to get hold of your brand new book, what is it called and where can they get it? So it is called the anti-burnout book and is available
这非常非常奇怪。别指望从这本书里发生那种事，但希望它能对人们有所帮助，因为我真正的目标是把这些东西传播出去，让人们使用它，改善他们的生活，并对他们的生活产生有益的影响。所以请去寻找那本关于技术、社交媒体和倦怠的免费电子书。太棒了。多么出色而美丽的资源，多么好的方式来确保你的工作不会最终只被锁在某个档案柜里。所以为你和你的出版团队点赞。那么，当人们非常渴望买到你的新书时，它叫什么名字，他们可以在哪里买到？它叫《反倦怠之书》（The Anti-Burnout Book），可以在
in any book shop. And if it's not available, you can ask for it to be ordered or obviously any online book shop as well. Great. I'll make sure I put a link for that and for your other books in the show notes. And most importantly, just before we leave, we've spoken about your Instagram page, we've spoken about your social media. Where can people follow you and connect with you, Emma? So I am still on social media as at The Psychology Mum. I don't post too regularly. A bit of a clue if you read the free e-book, why that is. And Facebook is the same.
任何书店买到。如果买不到，你可以要求预订，当然也可以在任何在线书店买到。太好了。我会确保在节目说明中放上这本书和你其他书的链接。最重要的是，在我们离开之前，我们谈到了你的Instagram页面，谈到了你的社交媒体。人们可以在哪里关注你并与你联系，Emma？我仍然在社交媒体上，账号是The Psychology Mum。我发帖不是很频繁。如果你读了那本免费电子书，就会知道原因。Facebook也是一样。
The free e-book is actually available via my substack, which is the Well-Being Society, and that's where it's available to download. So you can also find me there where I'll write longer form content as well. Perfect. Thank you so much for your time. I'm wishing you the very best with your new book baby and everything that comes thereafter. Do stay in touch.
那本免费电子书实际上可以通过我的Substack获得，也就是“幸福协会”（The Well-Being Society），你可以在那里下载。你也可以在那里找到我，我也会在那里写更长篇的内容。太完美了。非常感谢你的时间。祝你的新书宝宝以及之后的一切都顺利。保持联系。
Lovely to see you. Thank you, Marianne. Great to meet with you. Oh, thank you. Thank you so much for watching. Please do let us know in the comments if you've found this helpful. And if you read Dr Emma's book,
很高兴见到你。谢谢你，Marianne。很高兴见到你。哦，谢谢。非常感谢大家的观看。如果你觉得这有帮助，请在评论区告诉我们。如果你读了Emma博士的书，
please do take a moment to leave her a rating and a review wherever you buy your copy. If you love hearing about the stories of real-life clinical psychologists and how they got started and what their early career was like, I think you will love the clinical psychologist collective. It gets lovely reviews and it actually contains the collective wisdom of over 600 years of
请花点时间在你购买的地方为她留下评分和评论。如果你喜欢听关于现实生活中临床心理学家的故事，了解他们是如何开始的，以及他们早期的职业生涯是什么样的，我想你会喜欢《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。它获得了很好的评价，实际上包含了贡献者们超过600年的临床实践智慧。
clinical practice among the contributors. Wow, impressive stuff. And if you are excited for a career as a qualified regulated psychologist, I think you will also really love the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. That said, if you want to join for a longer time period, either six or 12 months, you will get free one-to-one time with me. Do check out more on my website, wwwd aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com.com. And if you're just here because you love to support me and my work, you can also consider joining my members-only podcast network,
哇，令人印象深刻。如果你对成为一名合格的注册心理学家的职业生涯感到兴奋，我想你也会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership），你每月只需30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。也就是说，如果你想加入更长的时间，比如6个月或12个月，你将获得与我一对一的免费时间。请在我的网站上查看更多信息，www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk。如果你在这里只是因为你喜欢支持我和我的工作，你也可以考虑加入我的会员专属播客网络，
which is available on Apple Podcasts, which you can get a three-day free trial for. where you get exclusive early access and exclusive subscriber only content. On YouTube, we have early access available and the backstage crew where you get exclusive content and then captivate where you can get early access and exclusive content too. Please do check out the details in the show notes. Let me know if you've got any questions. All of this helps me to support you via the podcast and other free work that I do. And it helps me know that you really rate and support me.
它在Apple Podcasts上提供，你可以获得三天的免费试用。在那里你可以获得独家的提前访问权和独家订阅者内容。在YouTube上，我们提供提前访问权和后台团队内容，你可以获得独家内容；在Captivate上，你也可以获得提前访问权和独家内容。请查看节目说明中的详细信息。如果你有任何问题，请告诉我。所有这些都有助于我通过播客和其他我做的免费工作来支持你。这让我知道你真的很看重并支持我。
as a creator. And of course the kindest thing you can do for any creator you do rate is to like and to subscribe and to share episodes. Please, if you do find any of my episodes helpful, I'd love you to start sharing to your stories on Instagram or across social media. Let people know you like it and why you do. I'd be so grateful and tag me too. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere on my social media. If you're looking to become a psychologist. then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne trey There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
作为一名创作者。当然，你能为你所看重的任何创作者做的最友善的事情就是点赞、订阅和分享剧集。拜托，如果你觉得我的任何一集有帮助，我很乐意你开始分享到你的Instagram故事或社交媒体上。让人们知道你喜欢它以及原因。我会非常感激，也请标记我。在我的所有社交媒体上，我都是Dr. Marianne Trent。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这个播客成为你的指南，它将陪伴你走上获得资格的道路。这就是《有抱负的心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是Marianne Trent博士。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。